des blindés russes impliqués en ukraine
sont ils équipés de caméras thermiques
française les avions les hélicoptères
russes d'un système de navigation
français selon nos confrères de disclose
la france aurait ainsi livré des
équipements militaires à la russie entre
2015 et 2020 malgré malgré l'embargo
européen sur les armes à destination de
moscou le site internet s'appuie sur des
documents confidentiel défense mais
aussi sur des informations publiques
jade les vins
des technologies militaires françaises
dernier cri équipes telles l'armée russe
en ukraine oui si l'on en croit le média
d'investigation en ligne disclose dans
sa toute dernière enquête selon le site
la france a discrètement fourni l'armée
russe entre 2015 et 2020 pour moderniser
ses troupes terrestres et aériennes
pourtant depuis août 2014 et le début de
la gare dans le donbass l'union
européenne impose un embargo sur les
armes en provenance et à destination de
la russie
mais d'après le média d'investigation la
france a profité d'une brèche juridique
l'embargo n'étant pas rétroactif les
gouvernements de françois hollande et
d'emmanuel macron ont choisi de
maintenir ses livraisons liées à des
contrats signés avant la mise en oeuvre
de ces sanctions
la france a permis l'exécution de
certains contrats passés depuis 2014 au
titre de la clause dite du grand-père un
contrat conclu avant l'annexion de la
crimée peut aller à son terme et les
livraisons d'équipements acheté avant
juillet 2014 peuvent être poursuivis
depuis 2015 paris a délivré 76 licence
d'exportation de matériel de guerre à la
russie pour un montant total de 152
millions d'euros pas d'armes létales
mais des équipements de haute
technologie parmi lesquels des caméras
thermiques destiné à équiper plus de
1000 tank russe des systèmes de
navigation et des détecteurs infrarouges
pour les avions de chasse et les
hélicoptères de combat de la force
aérienne russe
aujourd'hui ces équipements qui sont
installés sur des hélicoptères de combat
sur des bombardiers sur des tanks et
bien ils peuvent servir dans le conflit
en ukraine contre décidé le ministère
des armées se défend de ces accusations
et affirme faire preuve de transparence
selon son porte-parole aucun nouveau
contrat n'a été passé avec la russie
depuis 2014 et aucune livraison n'a été
effectué depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine